who decides somebody stays because if
you're sitting there like you said you
gotta put the cop on your K and sitting
there now this tell me all kinds of
dirty stuff anything machine and measure
the horniness and Ralphie's titties it's
illegal to [__] underaged one yes and
you go to jail sir and you get beat up
frankly as you should as you should for
[__] underage women if you're being
shitty to women that's really on your
fan base yeah
if your fan base don't tolerate that
[__] then they go [__] this guy I'm out
it yeah if they do then they go okay it
is what it is I'm sure there are a lot
of rock stars that were shitty to
[__] women people are like I we're
cool with that and then maybe there were
some there should be women oh they were
cold but that's really up to your
families yeah to decide and then up to
your peers if they won't associate I'm
pretty sure the fan base don't really
know how he deals with that's what I'm
saying like why would anybody know I
never got that intention yeah no because
you said like it's up to the fan base to
cancel him if he's like she wants let
you know oh now you talk yeah that's
that's the city yeah but um but yeah man
I you know i don't i just want to say
chris pedophilia i just want to say that
babbling on I couldn't do it yeah and
then Jeff Rossen got instantly to heat
you know the roast molester you know
what if I wasn't anyone to be President
I would wanted to be Shaq the Shaq of
doing Evan hailey one that could call to
you in right now
at something that he wants to bomb
Frank's think on saying but why Shaq
they didn't do anything I don't know I
don't like the basketball team I think
the best what instincts honed drop the
bomb on
I'm gonna dunk it call me what they say
but you know what this is this is when
it's like when you have a girlfriend
this word I think a lot of people don't
realize right is like we're shocked
we're shocked that a woman is capable of
these things and know under normal
circumstances you should be shocked
right but then you realize that she's a
bull bull crash she's a bull cracker
right and when you're a bull cracker you
have to deal with a woman and she was
like 10 years ago from another they're
all by if you're yeah if you're a
beautiful if you're like a bad [__]
beautiful beautiful beautiful because
I'm walking around my house actually I
don't he's somebody's paranoid
what they call in quotable paranoid
things about anybody who smokes as much
pot as him will believe anything for a
few minutes
have you think of anything for 30
seconds yeah he's believed in Allah and
geez jelly perfume in a lot of black
people's thoughts yeah
really yeah where's a bean people's
paranoia that white people dismiss as
nonsense and I come in I commend you
right I did I never told you this but I
think I did but anyway that you never
hit Carlos looking at you to me I just
got all no man just gonna push it
doesn't he know and yes just like you
know I can kill you you can see it in
Carlos his eyes in the clip back to that
mode which was like you know I was happy
for you you know because it was almost
like that goading yeah yeah me thing
yeah but you could see it in Carlos his
eyes like her dis guy Carlos Kevin Hart
little bastard yeah I love Kevin Kevin
amazing he's like my wife as far as like
the same thing like couple people I've
ever met that just had this [__] vibe
were you just like I want to be around
this person and that guy was a star from
I can't say the first day within six
months I was just like this [__] guy
is gonna be a juggernaut but even then I
had no idea what he was gonna do a
corporate recharg and all a miles before
this is I moved to LA I'm saying the two
double partment I just got there Patrice
coming out I said yo you need place ass
I got two bedrooms
you can come near my ex-wife at the time
you know I come home it's like afternoon
like four trees I'm like yo you all but
trace but trace I go on a bag open up
the door I said as big as computer oh
all I see is his back hunched over so
baby you all right
and I come in on my oh joy that you'll
get out get out get out
and so enormous headlining and I think
there were three or four comics who are
doing five maybe eight-minute sets and
at that time it was all the material
they had you know there were new comics
no okay if polished off I said I got
these jokes and now I'm gonna go out
with this guy he's a great headliner and
we're gonna do this big corporate gig
and so at the gig as they were starting
norm off the top said I'm just gonna go
out there and kind of warm up the crowd
you know do a little teaser and then you
guys do sets one coming so norm went up
and apparently did everyone else's
material did all the is it Caesarea and
the what I loved as I was told to me
they're like first up we those are the
only jokes we had but the worst thing
about it is norms jokes were better like
our jokes yeah so look he had three
hours and he was gonna do an hour on
this show so he was only doing it to
[__] with them and he said but we were
just mortified because like we it's not
like we have a lesser five minutes right
great it's like that was everything he
was just it was just a joke doing he's
like this weapon flopped and like a [__]
did you crowd work and just like the
motive lessness of it yeah
with them like for an hour hey wasn't
that great when I did your asks are you
thinking I must have been crazy that's
also only a joke for the other comic
yeah they said they saw like a pretty
okay opening and then what the hell
happened in the middle and the kind of
closers came back and he was still yeah
I just did that yeah oh my god the
famous Latino that but I don't have his
number anymore this is true this is this
has me almost shaking in my in my in my
my ego boots this [__] this visit or I
hear coming up this is this is this
public knowledge that oh yeah
holy [__] balls out big you talking this
is how famous this person is you talking
to now the thing is called you know a
Bernie Mac passed away so the Kings
economy can't really do the full tour
anymore right so so I hear it's gonna be
a new king as a comedy tour but there's
no Bernie Mac so here's the thing there
is no like fourth person to take Bernie
Mac place it is called three kings and a
heart tour and tell is be closer put you
over the top
[__] though here's the thing with
the UH with the three kings in heart
tour this is gonna there's gonna [__]
you up you know I talked about I don't
give a [__] they they said it they
wanted to do we just supposed to do the
One Show all-star weekend right that's
what we're supposed to do and that they
were talking about taking it out so
Steve Harvey was like you know I'll I
don't want to really do it
because Barney's not here it's hard for
me to go on stage like that without
Barney without burning he said you know
so he didn't really feel comfortable DL
said I'm going to do it that's like well
he wanted to do it for all-star weekend
because it was that big
so when they started talking about the
other date before Stephen said I was
like I don't want to do the whole tour
because I don't want to be a part of is
already now if you want to be honest you
disappeared you did he said is numbered
and if I don't find his number it will
not only go why don't we do the
challenge Patrice you call right now and
Kevin are next to the mic let's do the
challenge right now decide it's really
depressing her depresses me like you
know hey
if I'm [__] a girl I'll actually go
you should meet my friend Kevin it's uh
this Friday
you're talking to your special guests I
know I've been downgraded so I'll see
you Friday
[Laughter]
we should hey don't be an ass all right
now this is Jim Jim's got your [__]
right
I want my number here no I'm let's go
eat the day through I seem to turn down
a meal we're all the same page Patrice
is difficult you know right now I'm not
playing which I call Friday Kevin Hart
I'm calling you on Friday
all right hey Patrice what are you know
I see I'm in town I got a I got a do 106
& Park and all that stuff while I'm here
so yeah it's a no no he's saying like
when is it when it happened
I'm joking around but little care I'd
swear to God I don't it this is so
shocking to me because I'm telling you
we was we were you know we always close
but you know life makes things go
separately so but [__] I wake up and
I'm like what the fish [__] is that
[__] thing I'm proud and jealous at
the same time to be nice to hear you
what makes them that's what makes them
amaze like beyond you got understand you
see since he's been on the air
everything you said is true and he goes
this is the relation we haven't talked
about usin a while but when I talk to
him it's it's that fast you pick back up
do I miss the big son of a [__] I'm not
gonna lie to you I [__] dude why if I
what different got [__] kids now
alright I got kids they know I'm outta
[__] other Patrice's